[Musique]
je suis adrien nous garer appelé zerator
sur internet et je suis organisateurs du
g20 ce week end à losier veulent c'est
un marathon caritatif de jeu vidéo
organisé sur twitch pendant trois jours
vendredi samedi dimanche et le but est
de récolter des fonds pour une
association
cette année c'est l'institut pasteur
c'est la quatrième édition de ce
marathon caritatif pour nous mais c'est
la troisième année seulement qui
s'appelle the event la première fois
s'est échappé avant le gers et l
initiative de streamer qui nous avait
appelés à faire ce marathon là et les
années après on a créé notre propre
événement on avait fait donc la
croix-rouge publiques sans son compte
hier les stones on a voulu remettre le
couvert avec un cqp cela c'est à la
suite de médecins sans frontières l'an
dernier et d 1 million d'euros levés on
a eu environ je dirais 400 mails étaient
2 500 mails d'associations qui nous ont
sollicités pour dire est-ce qu'on peut
être candidat pour the elven 2019 et en
fait on a répondu la même chose à 37
associations on leur a dit que nous on
choisirait plutôt que la première
arrivée serait la première servie ce
serait plus simple est en fait un centre
pasteur faisait déjà partie de notre
short list laisser prendre des
associations qui font un peu l'unanimité
qui sont assez grosse qui sont reconnues
d'utilité publique
en fait il n'a pas de temps que cela en
france en tout cas pas rien de le dire
il y en a plutôt une quinzaine qu'une
centaine je dirais vraiment très grosse
toujours l'unanimité et c est
insu pasteur faisait partie de la short
list on essaie aussi de prendre les
associations qui ont un peu moins de
visibilité par rapport à des
associations comme sos pas les restos du
coeur typiquement qui ont déjà les
[ __ ] ont le téléthon potes qui sert
déjà beaucoup votre association
voilà la recherche c'est un domaine qui
est plutôt inconnu enfin de plus en plus
inconnu je trouve ça fait de moins en
moins de bruit dans notre génération
surtout quand je trouvais ça sympa de
mettre un petit peu de lumière voilà ce
domaine en fait donc oui on commence
aujourd'hui à 18 heures le vendredi et
on finit le dimanche soir lors leur
officiel c'est minuit
mais des fois on pousse une heure pas
deux trois ou quatre de plus peut-être
une heure si jamais vraiment un objectif
à atteindre
on peut penser mais c'est ce qu'on a
fait l'an dernier comment on récolte des
fonds c'est très simple en fait il ya un
biais 22 point fr donc c'est de voip
point fr c'est l'adresse du site qui
regroupe tous en fait on à la cagnotte
globale comment donner
qu'est ce que l'association que l'on se
connecte au stream qu'est ce qu'on peut
voir qui on peut voir donc en fait il ya
toutes les infos sur ce site là même un
néophyte peut aller voir il comprendra
tout à fait il ya très peu de lignes
c'est un incident plein de publicité ou
coincé c'est assez assez sobre et comme
ça non ça nous permet d'avoir tout de
suite les informations de mon droit et
les gens peuvent lever des fonds sur
certains streamé pas passer un message
ou pas d'ailleurs
et participez à des cagnottes à 18
heures pétantes j'espère tout le monde
sera derrière ma chaise et moi sur mon
stream j'allume le spray en fait j'ouvre
un petit peu l'événement est donc je dis
voilà je déclare j event ouvert et où
les streamer sont derrière moi et à
partir de ce moment là donc à 18h01
thomas sur sa machine sur son ordinateur
et à lui ou son live et dire bienvenue à
tous et chacun après se gère
individuellement en fonction de ce qu'il
ce qu'il a prévu pour le week end
[Musique]
alors l'an dernier on était une
quarantaine cette année on est proche de
fond tu as en thèse quand on est 50 50 e
et c'est donc ça demande un petit peu de
logistique en termes d'électricité
d'internet et tout et tout ça mais on
s'est bien débrouillé ça devrait être le
cas alors effectivement on a des
streamer qui sont très connus d'autres
moins le but ce n'est pas de france qui
fait forcément le plus de vues même si
évidemment il y en a qui font énormément
de vue on a le plus grand tueur français
caisse cousy typiquement on a l'un des
plus grands streamer de france qui
appelle gotaga on a vraiment des grosses
têtes des grosses pointures du streaming
et du jeu vidéo en france
mais il ya aussi les animateurs il ya
aussi des gens qui me paraît par exemple
ne joue pas mais pour le talk show où
les débats ou des choses comme ça il ya
des gens qui vont faire alors on voulait
organiser certaines activités peut pas
trop en dire mais il ya des choses qui
vont être pas forcément lié au gaming et
peut-être du sport il ya des gens qui
vont monter des mégots en live faille à
un peu plein de choses qui vont arriver
donc on est quand même aussi beaucoup
centré sur le gaming parce qu'évidemment
tout s'arrête la crème de gaming et
c'est important pour nous de montrer
qu'on est là aussi pour ça et que c'est
notre coeur de métier il ya un citron
faire de la musique
ces équipements mais voilà il ya
quelques noms qui sont connus le mot
c'est d'aller découvrir en live en vrai
parce qu'ils ont tous une personnalité
très différentes et c'est ça qui fait la
force de l'événement sur le premier
event qu'on avait organisé on avait levé
près de 500000 euros en fait en
additionnant les t-shirts en effet plus
un peu plus de cinq cent mille euros
et l'an dernier on avait fait un million
cent mille euros donnerait plus de
doubler c'était inespéré
on n'a évidemment pas tout imaginer de a
à z on n'a pas inventé caritatif
on s'inspire
on s'est inspiré plus ou moins
d'événements comme un génie ku et sgd ku
qui sont les games the quick qu'ils ont
fait aux états unis qui sont des
marathons de speed run de jeux vidéo sur
cinq jours le speed run c'est une
discipline qui consiste à finir un jeu
le plus vite possible mais en fait en
amérique le game the quick c'est un
marathon de cinq jours où plusieurs
speed run heures dans des gens qui font
ça sont invités à finir des jeux le plus
vite possible pendant cinq jours donc à
une centaine de jeux sont terminés à la
suite c'est des gens ce volet est par
contre un peu différent parce que c'est
un seul live un seul live où les gens se
relayent en fait et nous on s'est dit
bon on aimerait bien avoir sa à la
française mais comme on n'est pas des
spécialistes de speed run qu'on fait
juste du gaming pour l'adapter à notre
sauce et donc mais on ouvre tous les lie
en même temps alors ça a un côté pas
très pratique pour l'audience parce
qu'il doit d'avoir les yeux un peu
partout mais ça aussi le côté un peu
exceptionnel ou quand on arrive à choper
quelque chose sur un stream et bien se
dire ah [ __ ] j'étais là pour voir ça
donc c'est super
[Musique]
en fait chaque streamer ici à ce qu'on
appelle une donation gaulle c'est à dire
que sur le live y en a qui vont venir va
si sûr bon live ont atteint 1000 euros
je vais faire une action aussi sur mon
live on atteint 5000 euros je vais faire
une action
alors ça doit être ça peut être tout et
n'importe quoi ça peut être je joue à ce
jeu où je vais voir un certain streamer
ai je lu mclean la tête s'il est
d'accord
ou alors ben je vais jouer de la flûte
en plein milieu de l'événement et on
verra si j'arrive à sauver les gens
voilà il ya plein de trucs complètement
loufoque qui sont faits il ya même des
gens qui prévoit deux jours après
l'événement
typiquement on a un on en est là on l'a
on est à montpellier et il ya un
streamer de marseille qui a dit si
j'atteins une somme x ou y je rentre un
vélo de montpellier à marseille et genre
à la suite de l'événement il a dit bell
lundi je pars en vélo qui je vais vous
donner à ses surnoms ces règles là c'est
un peu la fourmilière on est à 12 heures
du début de l'événement mais comment
organise-t-on sable avec du temps et en
sachant s'entourer
moi je suis avec quelqu'un qui s'appelle
alexandre qui est mon bras droit ont les
deux et on a quelqu'un enfin on a deux
personnes avec mousse et timothée et et
mikari depuis son bas en rond et 4 et 1
on organise sa à 4 en s'entourant
prenant du temps ci prenant un peu à
l'avancé et on est aidé bien sûr par les
skieurs qui sont toutes deux bombes de
monter
voilà et euros du coup nous on connaît
aussi des partenaires typiquement la
région qui nous qui nous prête la salle
on les connaît depuis longtemps puisque
travaille avec eux donc on discute avec
eux en un gros etc
mais ouais on est quatre à organiser ça
et ça fonctionne pour l'instant le
matériel il ya un peu fou ya du prêt il
ya du
y'a du à ce qui amène avec moi moi
j'avais mon ordinateur on a environ 20%
des primeurs qui amènent leur propre
matériel et 80% qui est prêté par une
boîte aussi sa passion qui prêtent les
pc le rythme de sommeil de chacun
étaient assez libre jusqu'à l'an dernier
mais l'an dernier on a eu un peu pas des
abus mais des gens qui auront trente
heures voulait pas aller se coucher
alors on leur a dit d'entrée vous
coucher et cette année on a fixé une
règle c'est pas plus de 24 heures de
live d'affilée donc les gens peuvent
leur planning en fonction de ça il y en
a qui vont même se coucher à ces taux
sont fort pour revenir demain matin et y
en a d'autres qui au contraire vont
faire 15 heures vont aller se coucher
refaire 15 heures voilà on y en a qui
ont l'habitude de faire ça à d'autres -
il y en a qui peuvent le faire donc
moins
donc ça c'est un peu libre à chacun
[Musique]